climate change is boring don't get me
wrong it's incredibly important it's
just that the story of climate change is
not especially compelling and that's
when the carbon dioxide concentration
reached 400 parts per million when I
started making this video I thought that
everyone knew the story but apparently I
was wrong what do you feel about climate
change so I think Australia is the most
affected by the climate change that's
because I'd rather say the weather there
is in layer the hole in the ozone layers
I think Americans yeah and whereas
before they used to be a natural layer
up there that blocked things that layer
seems to be getting its its dig and so
more heats coming down hmm the ozone
layer and therefore our seasons are
changing the hole in the ozone layer is
causing a problem yeah okay the hole in
the ozone layer is a problem but it's
not a major cause of climate change to
recap we are burning fossil fuels
releasing carbon dioxide into the
atmosphere which traps a slightly more
thermal energy causing the overall
temperature of the planet to rise have
you changed anything about your life
because climate change is happening I
recycled it
we recycle more we recycle a lot I think
in England yeah do you like more things
like recycling lots of recycling
recycling was like in plastic and paper
putting plastic in the right bin and
paper in the right bin and stuff like
this okay
again recycling is very important but
it's not really going to reduce
greenhouse gas emissions which come
mainly from energy use and
transportation so what I've learned is
lots of people don't know how climate
change works and don't know what to do
about it
what's worse is there's so much
confusion that some people don't think
humans are responsible I'm a doubter
what does that mean it means I don't
know whether it is or it isn't you get
seven show flick ting opinions on it and
they all should be coming from reputable
sources here's the thing the vast
majority of climate scientists agree
that climate change is happening and
that humans are playing a significant
role but the public doesn't see this
broad consensus because well there are
arguments made to the contrary by
businesses with vested interests those
who stand to lose if a price is put on
carbon now these people will make up
stories whatever they want things like
Al Gore and his pals just invented
climate change in order to make
themselves rich and famous meanwhile the
scientists respond with carefully worded
predictions that would result in a
rising of temperature of between one
point four and two point six degrees
Celsius that is within a 90% confidence
interval by the year 2050 I want to
listen to this story again this is why
scientists have had such a tough time
informing the public about climate
change it's much easier to tell a
compelling story if you can make up
whatever you want then if you have to
stick to the truth climate change is
like Armageddon just instead of a giant
earth crushing asteroid it's slightly
more of a invisible odorless gas and
instead of the imminent destruction of
the planet it's a gradual warming over
decades see our brains are well adapted
to a deal with clear and present danger
they're not so good handling complex
long-term probabilistic forecasts which
is kind of why we have governments
they're meant to act in our best
interest especially in the case of
complex long-term problems and in fact
last year the Australian government
implemented a carbon tax which seemed to
be working great it was reducing carbon
emissions and then this year they
repealed that carbon tax the first
government in the world to do something
like that and my question is why you
know there is a UN climate summit coming
up next month
and you can actually win a trip to go
there and ask your questions to the
world leaders if you're between the ages
of 13 and 21 head over to ask why why
not org where you can submit a
one-minute video asking why why not
questions like why would you scrap a
carbon
that was working why not join the rest
of the world in putting a price on
carbon I mean the real reason I find
climate change boring is because we know
what the problem is the science is well
established and the solutions are fairly
obvious and yet action is not being
taken so if you feel like I do perhaps
you should take some action and maybe we
can change this story and make it a
little bit more interesting
this video was sponsored by the climate
reality project but it really opened my
eyes because I really thought we already
all knew the facts but clearly we don't
so maybe we need to spend more time
educating the people around us